The answer is no, we don't have enough information, we should make an instance
variable. The xCoord and yCoord variables are parameters in the constructor.
Which means when the constructor is done running, they go away. So then when
addFriend is called later, xCoord and yCoord don't exist anymore. We can't get
the coordinates from the friend variable. We're talking about the coordinates
for where to draw the circle. And the friend probably doesn't know anything
about where the upper left corner of the current object is. We could take the
coordinates in as parameters in the addFriend method, so it would be
addFriend(Person friend) int x int y. But it would be a little weird if every
time you called addFriend, you also had to pass in the x and y coordinates that
you originally passed in in the constructor. So if we decide to make instance
variables for x and y, where would we initialize them? That's one for you to
think about yourself.